can you tell us how the selling came to
be was when I came real estate that
would mean me a real job well the
director Emily Lou who produced with us
she called me up about six years ago and
said that she wanted to direct a movie
wanted me to write him start everybody
went to college together and so she had
access to things with some assets do we
have and she said well I have a house I
have access to and like the Sacramento
area that's empty that we can use to
shoot anything in there so if we can
find something that takes place like in
this one location I'll be great so some
you know what can happen in empty house
one of the house real estate love ghost
stories love haunted house movies and so
I thought what about the real estate
agent try to sell on a house and and so
that idea stuck and then of course it
was supposed to take place mostly in the
house and then of course start getting
overly ambitious in one minute turned
out that it was cheaper to rent a house
and shoot down here than to move
everyone up right but that was the
intent is for we had that we had a free
location that we didn't end up using but
it was the inspiration for for what I
came to be yeah okay so you throw it
around move the location all right and
then where did you come up with some of
the characters are they based on people
knew really well I've had to write a
part for me i had read a park for you I
had all right apart from me and so those
are basically just sort of skewed
versions of ourselves or sort of
personas that we need to normally play
our types and then you always have to
have an exorcist nay anh
so we wrote a goofy Exorcist and and
then there's a there's a plot line in
the movie where my mother is sick and
that was based on my real mother who who
had cancer and so that was based on her
and one of the main characters there's
the there's the rival real estate agent
I was right an apartment in for Janet it
was written for her she's a good friend
and and then you know you gotta have the
sidekick buddy character so the guy who
makes my character look courageous
Sydney we made him like sort of a really
just really just scaredy cat Don Knotts
style yeah coward to my handy Taylor
you